[music]
I'm so excited to tell you about how at
Zapier we are empowering our support
team to ship code. Before I tell you
about that, has anybody here visited the
Grand Canyon?
It's a good amount. Anybody rafted
through the Grand Canyon?
I see one person. I just got off an
18-day trip rafting through the Grand
Canyon over 200 miles. It was
incredible. No internet, no cell
service. The moment I got off, I found
out I was giving this talk. I didn't
think about uh work at all on the river,
but once I got off, I started thinking
about the parallels between the Grand
Canyon and Zapier. And we have one thing
in common, and that is erosion.
Now, natural erosion happens over
millions of years with wind, water, and
time. It creates the beautiful canyon
that we experience, and it's never
stopping, always continuing. At Zapier,
we have over 8,000 integrations built on
thirdparty APIs, and they are constantly
changing, which I'm now thinking of as
app erosion.
We've been around for 14 years. Some of
our apps are that old. API changes and
deprecations impact us and create
reliability issues. Again, it never
stops.
So, I like to think of our apps as like
layers in the Grand Canyon and they need
constant attention.
So, if we were to create our own Zap
Your Canyon and our apps would be at the
walls, here's our support team flowing
down the middle watching out for app
erosion. And we have a backlog crisis.
Tickets were coming in faster than we
could handle them. creates integration
reliability issues, poor customer
experience, even churn. So to solve for
app erosion, we kicked off two parallel
experiments. The first was moving
support from just triaging to also
fixing these bugs. This experiment
number one and experiment number two, we
were asking, can AI help solve app
erosion faster?
So let's jump into experiment one. This
get kicked off two years ago but had to
start with the why. We needed to get
that buy in to empower our support team
to ship code.
So app erosion is one of the major
sources of bugs coming through to from
support to engineering. So there's a big
need support is eager for this
experience to a lot of them want to go
into engineering eventually and
unofficially many support members were
already helping to maintain our apps.
This moves us into how we started this
out. Put on some guard rails. We started
with just four target apps to uh focus
our fixes on. engineering was set to
review any merge requests coming from
support and we kept the focus on app
fixes.
So jumping into experiment two, this is
what I've been leading for the last
couple of years. How can we use codegen
to help solve for app erosion and so
fortuitously the name of this project is
scout which ties in so well to the Grand
Canyon experience that I've just been
through.
As any good product manager, we start
with discovery. We did some dog fooding,
so I shipped some app fixes. Uh we
shadowed engineers and support team
members as they were going through the
app fix process. We designed out uh what
are the pain points experienced along
the way? What are the phases of the work
and how much time is spent?
One big discovery we had is how much
time is spent gathering the context
going to the thirdparty AP API docs even
crawling the internet looking for
information about a bug that's emerging
maybe somebody else has already
discovered and solved for it outside of
Zapier internal context logs all of this
is a lot of context to go and search for
as a human uh and a lot to gro and work
through. This is something we knew we
needed to solve for.
Where we started with all this great uh
opportunities and pain points is we
started building APIs that we believed
would solve for these individual um pain
points. And some of these APIs are using
LLMs to you know for our diagnosis tool
gathering all that context on behalf of
the uh support person engineer and
curating that context and building a
diagnosis that's [clears throat] using
an LLM and then some aren't like we have
a unit test uh unit test generator is
but the um test case finder is simply
using a search query to look for the
right test cases to pull in for your
unit test. We built a bunch of APIs. We
had a bunch of great ideas. So there was
a lot for us to test with, but we ran
into some challenges in this first
phase. We had APIs, but they were not
embedded into our engineers process. So
our tool I just said they don't like to
go to so many web pages to find all
their context. They would love all this
information to come to them. And yet our
web interface where we've we've created
a playground we call autocode internally
where you can come and play around with
our APIs and our ask to the teams was
come try out our APIs and give us
feedback.
Now this is just one more window to go
to. So we didn't get a lot of engagement
also because we had shipped so many uh
APIs our team was spread pretty thin.
Cursor launched at the same time which
has gotten great adoption at Zapier.
We're all huge fans of Cursor. But from
our side, it made some of our tools no
longer necessary.
But there was one major win in this
phase, which is one of our APIs became a
support darling. It's diagnosis. That
number one pain point of needing to go
out and find all of your context, curate
it for yourself so you can start solving
the problem. We were doing that on uh
the sport team's behalf with the
diagnosis API
and support loved it enough that they
decided to embed it into their process.
They asked us to build a zap year
integration on our autocode APIs so they
could embed it into their zap that
creates the jur ticket from the support
issue and now diagnosis is included.
So embedding tools is the key to usage
as we find out. So how can we embed more
of our tools? Well, then MCP spins up
and that solves our problem.
We can now embed these API tools into
our engineers workflow. Specifically,
our engineers are pulling in these MCP
tools as they're using cursor.
Our builders using Scout MCP tools are
leaving the IDE less, spending more time
in one window.
Still coming into challenges. One of our
uh our our key tool diagnosis
uh is so valuable to pull all that
context and to provide a recommendation,
but it takes a long time to run. Now, we
might run down that runtime. However, as
you're working synchronously on a ticket
in your ID, this was frustrating. We
also weren't keeping up with the
customization needs. Not only did MCP
launch and we started leveraging it, Zap
Your MCP launched too. And some of our
tools, if we weren't keeping up with the
customization needs, our engineers
internally looked to Zap Your MCP, which
is great. We're all on the same team
solving the same problem, but some of
our tools had a dead end. Also adoption
was scattered. We had a whole suite of
tools and we thought there was value in
each of them as it solves for different
problems across the different stages.
Not every engineer was using our tools
and if they were using tools, they're
only using a few of them. So we have
tool usage. We're happy about that. But
we were under the hypothesis that true
value is going to come from tying these
tools together.
So what if we owned orchestration of
these tools rather than saying here's a
suite of tools you use them as you wish
what if we combined them and created an
agent to orchestrate this. So this we
are calling scout agent. We take that
diagnosis run that against a ticket uh
use that information to actually spin up
a codegen tool which will then produce a
merge request using all the right
context.
So who would benefit the most from
orchestration? There are several
integration teams at Zapier who are
solving for these app fixes of various
levels of complexity and there's the
support team. So when we're saying who
should be our first customer scout
agent, we were thinking it should
probably be the the team fielding small
bugs that are emergent and coming hot
off the queue which is the support team.
And now our two experiments merge
and we have scout agent. We are building
for the support team.
And this is the flow of how it works.
Support is submitting an issue to scout
agent. We first categorize the issue. We
next assess its fixability.
Not every issue that comes from support
can be fixed. If we thinks it's fixable,
we'll move on to generating a merge
request. At that point, the support
team, this is the first time they're
picking up the ticket. It already has a
merge request attached to it. They'll
review and test. If it's not satisfying
what they believe is the actual solution
or the the what what the solution should
be to best address the customer's need,
they will make a request for an
adjustment that can happen right in
GitLab, which is where we do our work
and Scout will do another pass and
hopefully at that point we've gotten it
right and support can submit that MR for
review from engineering.
How we are running Scout, it's all
kicked off by a zap. This is a picture
of one of our zaps. There are many zaps
that's run this whole process and it
embeds right into our support team's
zaps. We do a ton of dog fooding at
Zapier.
We first run diagnosis and post that
result to the Jira ticket saying what
the categorization is if we believe it's
fixable. And then if we do believe it's
fixable, we then are kicking off a
GitLab CI/CD pipeline.
And we run three phases in that
pipeline. plan, execute and validate to
generate this merge request. The tools
used in this pipeline is Scout MCP. So
all those APIs we invested in a year ago
now are really coming together and we're
orchestrating it uh within the GitLab
pipeline and we're also leveraging
cursor SDK.
Once the M merge request has been
completed, we attach it to Jira and
support picks it up.
The latest addition to this is doing a
rapid iteration once a um uh once a
ticket has been posted with the merge
request and support team is looking at
it and they say, you know, it needs some
tweaks to save them more time so they
don't have to go pull that down to their
ID, do the fixes, and push it back up.
they can simply chat with the uh scout
agent in gitlab that'll kick off another
uh pipeline which does that phase with
that new feedback and posts the new
merge request
on our side we want to make sure scout
agent is working so we ask three
questions categorization right is was it
actually fixable uh and was the code fix
accurate so far we have two eval
to 75% accuracy for categorization and
fixibility. As we get more feedback and
process more tickets, those become our
test cases and we can move forward
improving scout agent over time. So what
has been scout agents impact on app
erosion
40% of supports support teams app fixes
are being generated by scout. So we're
doing more of the work on behalf of the
support team.
This is resulting and for some of our
support team it's doubling their
velocity from one to two tickets per
week which already is amazing. That's
going from a support team that wasn't
shipping any fixes, well unofficially
they were sometimes to now shipping one
to two per week per person to now
shipping three to four with the help of
Scout.
Another uh process improvement, Scout
puts potentially fixable tickets right
there in the triage flow. takes away a
lot of the friction of looking for
something to grab from the backlog.
It's not just the support who's
benefiting, it's also engineering.
Engineering manager said, uh, it's a
great example of when it works. This
tool allows us to stay focused on the
more complex stuff.
And if you take away anything from this
talk, I hope it is that there is a
really powerful magic between support
and empowering them with codegen and
allowing them to ship fixes because they
have three superpowers. The first they
are the closest to customer pain which
mean they're closest to the context that
really matters for figuring out what's
the problem and how to solve it. They're
also troubleshooting in real time. These
tickets aren't stale. the context is
fresh, the logs aren't missing. You put
this ticket into a engineering backlog
months later, you might not get access
to those logs anymore. And then three,
they're best at validation.
You've again, you put the same ticket
into an engineering backlog. The
solution an engineer might come up with
may change the behavior and that might
be good for some customers but might not
necessarily be best for that one
customer who wrote in about the problem.
And one other major benefit of this is
support team members who have been part
of this experiment are now engineers.
I want to say thank you to the amazing
team who's helped built this process or
built all the tools and the scout agent.
Andy is actually here in the audience.
So shout out to Andy. If you want to
talk about any of the technical bits,
he's here. And I want to impress upon
you two things. We're hiring, but mostly
if you haven't rafted through the Grand
Canyon, please consider it. It's
lifechanging and you should go with ORS.
Thank you very much. [applause]
Heat. [music]
[music]